morning good morning berto what no
pancakes
jake's not here this weekend why not
apparently jake took something i said
out of context and repeated it in front
of his mother and
she overreacted as is her nature what
did you say numbnuts
all i said was if your domestic chores
are taken care of by one woman
and you have an active sexual life with
other women you don't necessarily need
yet
another woman with whom to tie the
matrimonial knot
oh and which category do i come in under
well i got to say it's the sweet loving
berta because this place is a mess
okay i'm out of here no no wait
berta come sit talk
mommy and me time over already he hates
me
no i don't please berta i need you
i'm done i want to go home i'm begging
you
oh all right
so why do you hate your mother so i'm
having this nice mother's day dinner
with my [ __ ] daughter and her idiot
boyfriend
and suddenly the front door comes down
and the room fills with tear gas next
thing i know i'm belly up on the floor
hacking out along while the cops are
dragging out bonnie and claude in
handcuffs
come to find out that the money that i
loaned them to open a tanning salon was
used to turn my tool shed
into a hydroponic platform unbelievable
your daughter came to visit on mother's
day well sure what kind of ungrateful
mutt doesn't visit their mother on
mother's day
one year i forgot let it go when's my
birthday excuse me
you heard me
what's that going to do with anything
you don't know your mother's birthday
well not by heart charlie
why she changes it all the time just the
year
not the day hey i just realized
something
i can leave and you why do you enable
this behavior
why i'll tell you why
because your brother is the embodiment
of the can do roll up your sleeve spirit
that made this country great
he never gets discouraged he goes after
what he wants and he doesn't know the
meaning of the word quit
and if the days should come when any man
no matter how humble can't go out there
and soil the loins of some hot little
dancer well
i don't want to live in that america
oh beautiful for spacious skies
forever waves are great
here's what you do make friends with the
janitor they usually have their own
bathroom
okay just never drink out of his thermos
all right and don't believe him if he
tells you he loves you
damn it i miss out one night son of a
[ __ ]
good morning buddy i didn't like your
eggs in an easter basket
scrambled it is good morning good
morning
what you doing cooking breakfast how do
you like your eggs
sunny side up scrambled it is
cooking for dummies no offense jake i'm
actually cooking for everybody
what brought this on i don't know i
i'd expand my horizons a bit uh-huh
what i'm just trying to figure out how
scrambled eggs are gonna get you laid
you and me both
is that what i think it is yeah i got a
prescription
god i love california
just walk into a store and buy your weed
no more slapping out to proceed and
trading a piece of tail for a short bag
of stems and seeds
you're welcome to join me here no no not
while i'm working
all right okay i'm done working
man if i'd known you like the wacky weed
i wouldn't have spent the last eight
years getting baked under the deck
you know when i was on break
actually this is the first time i've
touched the stuff since the zz top
concert in 92.
i got so paranoid to lock myself in a
porta potty and trying to tunnel home
well good news pot's a lot stronger now
what do you think
i've rolled better joints on the back of
a motorcycle while digging a bullet out
on my boyfriend's shoulder
all right fine you try it
wow man i hope this helps me sleep
i can't take another night wandering
around the house thinking about chelsea
yeah yeah boo-hoo let's fire up this bad
boy
do it again no no oh come on please do
it again do it again
all right all right last time
bachelor's we don't need no sticking
badges
okay okay i got one i got one
some folks called a sling blade i call
it a casual blade
i like them french fried taters
oh good idea
where are you going to the pier to get
some of the french rotators
wait wait wait wait wait what i love you
bernard i love you too charlie
give me a thousand dollars
why well if you have to ask you don't
really love me
oh and and pretzels get some pretzels
brothels
we don't need no stinking pretzels
oh man i am so lucky to have her in my
life
all i could find was donuts and chalopas
hey rose
wait you can see her yeah
why can't you
what the hell is going on you're
imagining
berta
are you really here
i don't know am i
call me
okay roll another fatty and let's polish
off these donuts
charlie was the best boss i ever had
i needed a day off sure berta no problem
i needed a couple extra bucks sure berta
no problem
all he ever asked in return was clean
sheets and hosing the vomit off the
occasional
drug-haddled hooker
the beautiful story can i count on you
to keep the house clean until i sell it
can i count on you to keep paying me
well there's virtually no money in
charlie's estate but i'd be happy to pay
you once the house sells
then that's when i'll clean it
everything okay with you and mary
poppins
are you struggling if i don't eavesdrop
i've got nothing to tweet about
the problem is she's english stiff upper
lips and all that
you should date a nice polish girl
you don't say oh yeah those commies
they're all
freaks
sex is the only thing they didn't have
to stand in line and wait for
good to know i think i'll stick with zoe
i just wish i could get her to relax you
know let go
me i'm just the opposite i can get off
leaning against the dryer with a couple
of sneakers
is that in of my nikes or something when
when
listen if you want to loosen up the
duchess of dolan sack
you might try slipping on one of my
special brownies
i got a fresh batch in the fridge you
know from my
glaucoma
thank you i don't want to have to get
zoe loaded to enjoy sex with me
suit yourself doesn't want to get her
loaded what's the matter with kids today
men